clairement le fait d'avoir un candidat
en face de toi qui es sûr de son projet
professionnel qui est sur deux de ces de
ses points forts et qui connaît ses
points faibles mais qui sait et qui met
en place des actions pour les améliorer
ça fait clairement la différence pour un
recruteur
[Musique]
démontrer aux recruteurs que vous êtes
intéressé par ce qu'il vous dit sur le
post sur l'entreprise sur votre
potentiel future équipe
le fait de prendre des notes le fait
d'avoir incarné le fait d'avoir un stylo
vous adopter tout de suite une posture d
coutu ne pose-t-il une posture plus
attentive en fait à ce qu'il va vous
dire et en plus les notes ça peut être
très positif parce que si jamais le
lendemain de l'entretien vous souhaitez
écrire un email
pour réitérer votre motivation et faire
un bilan de ce que vous avez compris de
l'entretien c'est notre là seront très
précieuses
le plus important quand vous passez un
entretien embauches et dans cette étape
d'introspection c'est de savoir
concrètement où est ce que vous voulez
aller professionnellement parlante
comment est ce que vous voulez y aller
et par quel biais et avec qui est ce que
vous voulez y aller autrement dit quelle
est votre ambition professionnelle
comment est ce que vous souhaitez
arrivait à cette ambition
professionnelle et à partir du moment où
tout ça est clair dans votre tête
ça ça se ressent par l'entretien parce
que le recruteur va vous challenge et
sur ce sujet là et donc quand c'est
clair dans votre tête et quand ça se
ressent l'entretien clairement ça son
effet si votre projet professionnel
n'est pas encore précis par exemple si
on veut travailler dans le marketing
mais qu'on sait pas exactement ce qu'on
veut faire mais qu'on postule pour un
poste en tant que chef de produit on
peut regarder quelles sont les étapes
d'après du post on truque que chef de
produit est tout simplement en entretien
ça donnera en fait la sensation aux
recruteurs que concrètement vous voyez
évoluer dans le poste pour lequel vous
postulez
mais également et potentiellement dans
l'entreprise pour laquelle vous postulez
[Musique]
il faut vraiment que vous vous posiez et
que vous fassiez un bilan sur vos points
forts et vos points faibles il faut que
vous puissiez vous renseigner sur
l'entreprise la culture les valeurs
l'actualité de l'entreprise mais
également du secteur de l'entreprise que
vous puissiez bien revenir la fiche de
poste pour en comprendre ou en tout cas
essayer d'en comprendre la totalité des
missions et justement s'il ya des points
à éclaircir noté des questions sur un
bout de papier et les poser en entretien
être curieux c'est une très grande
qualité et donc si jamais on n'a pas
forcément l'information qu'on souhaite
sur la fiche de poste ou qu'il ya un
petit point à éclaircir il faut pas
hésiter à aller chercher sur internet
par rapport aux postes à regarder un
petit peu ce qu'on peut trouver
[Musique]
il faut pas hésiter à poser des
questions pertinentes avec le poste de
préférence vraiment vous êtes en
entretien donc certes c'est vous qui
passez un entretien embauche par contre
aujourd'hui clairement l'entretien il
faut vraiment le voir comme de la drague
entre guillemets c'est vous qui devez
vous vendre mais c'est également
l'entreprise qui doit se vendre
donc ce n'est pas vraiment ce n'est plus
vraiment un entretien à sens unique
aujourd'hui clairement quand vous êtes
un entretien d'embauché vous êtes aussi
là pour savoir si vous vous plairez dans
l'entreprise si vous allez aimer
travailler avec le manager que vous avez
en face de vous si la culture de
l'entreprise vous plaît si le poste
correspond à vos attentes